Is a plant-based or alkaline diet best for the treatment for cancer?
We get that question a lot. Should I go on a keto diet? Because oh my gosh, I read this book on
keto diets and cancer. Should I go on a plant-based diet? Should I not do any animal protein whatsoever?
Should I become a vegan or a vegetarian? Is that the best thing? Should I go on an alkaline diet?
Is that the best thing? The truth is that cancer needs a growing cancer. So cancer is cells
and rapid replication. That means they're highly metabolic. That means they're very hungry.
So they're looking for a fuel source. Is that fuel source always strictly glucose?
The answer is no. Sometimes it's not glucose. Sometimes it's glutamated,
serrated, and those are different amino acids that are for protein. So a person whose
cancer is driven mainly through amino acids, that is the main fuel source, then yes, a plant-based
diet would be best for that person. But a plant-based diet, let's say, a typical
like Gershon, Juicy, I'm going to start Juicy right away. Well, Juicy can be high in glucose.
So your cancer is mainly through glycolysis through the breakdown of glucose, then that might
not be the right diet. So how do I know? Because there's these extreme ends of ketogenic,
which is very, very low sugar, very, very low glucose, but maybe higher
the aspect of proteins versus a Juicy Gershon type diet, which is very high in glucose.
So it's just, it's very difficult to know which one, which diet is best for you. So in our clinic,
we test for that. But let's say you don't come to our clinic. How do I know what diet is best for me?
There is some data out there on metabolic typing. That's what Dr. Gonzales used to do,
is do metabolic typing, and he did produce some literature on that that you could take a very
long questionnaire and get an idea of what could possibly be fuel in your cancer. We have found that
to not be extremely effective in knowing what can fuel my cancer. Also, the struggle with that is
that cancer is constantly trying to survive and fight a fuel source. So if your fuel source in your
cancer is mainly glucose, and you go on a ketogenic like diet, don't have to necessarily get total
and totally into ketosis, but if you go on a ketogenic like diet and you're starving, your cancer,
that's the goal. But your cancer can switch quite easily because it's trying to find a fuel source
and it can be fueled through a different pathway. So diets for cancer patients may need to switch
over time. So if your cancer is fed mainly through amino acids and you cut down on the animal proteins
and you find that your cancer is starting to go into revision and then six months later it starts to take
off again. What's the matter? I've been staying on my diet. It might be because the fuel source switched.
So if you're not a patient of ours and you don't have a way to find out what's the best diet for me,
maybe a balanced diet, maybe low in animal proteins, doesn't mean you're going to go off them completely
and get rid of all your simple carbs and try to get on a low carb diet. That is what we call a mixed diet.
Most people that we test, honestly test positive for dairy being a driver for cancer. So I would
suggest in general dietary cutting out dairy or cutting down dairy to a minimal is beneficial and
it really has to do with the sort what dairy is. And we're talking about what comes out of a
cow's udders. We're talking about dairy. What dairy is is to make a baby cow grow quickly and
gain weight quickly and become an adult cow. So it has growth factors in there, it has hormones in
there, it has all sorts of other impurities in there as well. Even organic dairy still has hormones
and growth factors in it because that's what dairy is supposed to do. So that I would say in general
is the right diet to do. But if you don't have a way to test it, the only way to test it really is to
try one of these diets and see if it slows your cancer growth. Of course you have to have some
in these subjective or objective data to be able to measure if you're slowing the cancer growth. But
that's one way to do it is try a diet, see how you're doing, you're doing real well. If you're like
you're in a relative state of remission, then stay on that diet. If things change in your cancer,
wake up and start to grow it again, then think about switching diets because it's looking for a fuel
source.